blake shelton premiered a new song on
nbc's
new year's eve show and people are not
very impressed so the song is called
minimum wage
and the hook is girl your love can make
a man feel rich on minimum wage
yeah so some of the twitter reaction was
millionaire country singer blake shelton
debuting a song on nbc about how love
can make them feel rich on minimum wage
odd timing with millions unemployed and
struggling during a pandemic
and what does blake shelton know about
minimum wage
and another person wrote the irony of
listening to a millionaire blake shelton
singing about love on minimum wage at
the end of 2020
might be lost on its target audience
another person said losing my mind
watching blake shelton a man who has 100
million dollars saying
your love is money you make me which is
not we said feel rich on minimum wage
uh to close out 2020. so here's a bit of
a song when blake performed it on nbc's
new year's eve
[Music]
yeah your love can make a man feel rich
on minimum wages
the storm says ah can someone say out of
touch yeah do you think this is out of
touch keisha
i don't i don't know this one's a tough
one okay blake for me
he's in love okay and it's it's like
he's gushing
it's all he wants to sing and talk about
and i get it
he's trying to say i feel like the
sentiment is sweet that it doesn't
matter how much money you're making
this love makes you feel like you're on
top of the world that's what i took from
it
i do think the timing sucks i don't like
that people are listening to it and
feeling
not happy with it or feeling offended i
don't want anyone to ever feel offended
by anything
that makes me feel sad but i think blake
shelton is shown unless i'm missing
something from what i've seen on the
on the outside he's always come across
humble
and and generous and considerate and
even on the voice i've always found him
to be very likable and charming
and and really grounded so it would be
different if this was
i don't want to say a kanye west but you
know someone that we know for having a
huge ego or a certain
you know out of touch uh idea blake
seems more grounded and also it's
country music like do we really think
that you know carrie underwood is going
to smash the man's car now does she go
catch a case she worth too much money
like there's a lot of country songs and
i'm like that's not true
i know you're not doing that anymore
you're not in that pickup truck honey i
saw you in the rolls
in la like last week you don't even have
a pickup truck anymore i mean that's a
thing
okay that's a thing but i don't know i
know people don't like it
i just like blake and he's in love okay
go ahead
yeah no i i i don't think it's a blake
shelton song that was the black guy at
the end of 2020 i think it was the
reaction to blake shelton's song
that was the black eye to the end of
2020 lyrics are as keisha knows
their innuendo and their metaphor you
make me feel grounded when i'm on the
moon i can you
like all of this stuff and i don't
expect people to take things literally
bruce springsteen saying working on a
highway when he was worth more money
than blake shelton was
and nobody came after him this is just
what artists
do i have no time for somebody taking a
love song
with a metaphor that was not designed to
say
i'm poor it was a metaphor to i could
have nothing
you could make me feel whole i could be
wounded you could make me feel
unwounded i could be poor you could make
me feel rich i could be a lot of
different things you could make me feel
the exact
opposite for somebody to nitpick the
hell out of a love song
to a guy who actually does a lot of
great there's a lot of people
who don't do the things that blake
shelton does
get bent i have no time for this zero
she says come on people are too
sensitive that says this is bad timing
love isn't going to pay the back rent
ali says it's just a turn of a phrase
but it is annoying for some reason
quick says shut up and sit down i don't
listen to country music anyway shell
says that was insensitive blake but the
song isn't that bad though yeah i mean
there's tons of songs that use that kind
of metaphor like you said keisha i think
it's just how literal
the phrase minimum wage is i think
that's what is getting to people and
yeah in these times i think it's just
it's too on the nose blake i think it
was a little more like
yeah i don't need money to love you or
whatever you can do that kind of thing
but i think it's just a little too on
the nose to say
even though i'm on minimum wage it
doesn't matter
people are hurting right now yeah and
every hand people have always been
touched
those people are rich everyone the mixer
the master the agent the label everybody
was like rich
listening to it not even right not even
hearing it
but it did offend people and it offend a
lot of people it was trending i thought
that was very interesting it wasn't like
it was one or two it was a large group
of people
i agree with you though graham i feel
like the word minimum wage
is like kind of a sticky
sticky one sets people off yeah yeah
it's a trigger word but i
you know yeah poor blake ross we love
blake
get back
it's a country song for god's sake